I'd like to welcome slavo
xak hope this will work uh thanks very
much I'm honored to be here and I also
prefer the situation today where there
is a at least a hope that we will do a
chance that we will do more Theory and
so on but uh I don't want to disappoint
you too much because I was nonetheless
told that like the public is not only
philosophers so what I will try to do is
simply prolong the reflections of of the
last days on the end of the world and so
on which means our ideological
constellation today where are we moving
what does this mean well my first
Association when you
say the end of the world it is
culturally for me is does any of you
know
this quite terrifying song but I think
it's if there ever was a symptom of
where we are today this is it this mega
mega he Gangam Style which started in
South Korea then all around the world I
was told that already in the United
States it's already on the second place
and so on what interests me here is
uh how it functions my small son who
listened to it draw my attention to it
that you know if you play it on YouTube
you have how many hits and then you have
positive negative opinions that negative
opinions are much larger it's like as my
son told me you're big guy if you look
at Justin Bieber you find the same like
5 to1 but nonetheless people remain
stuck onto it they listen to it and so I
even then found a text on this hit
Gangam Style where they say that's how
it effectively functions it's not that
you like it but practically everyone
tells me the same when you first hear it
you find it
disgusting but in a weird way
pleasurably disgusting you become haed
by it you know it's like when something
is so disgusting that fascinates you and
you say oh it's horrible let's take a
look again at it how horrible it is and
then slowly my son who is 11 now ends up
listening at least 50 times per day to
eat second thing uh although it is uh
quasy religious experience like in Korea
a friend send me some video Clips this
stupid song was performed uh at a
stadium with over 100,000 people all in
a TR and so on what is so interesting is
how critics false I claim fake leftist
critics try to convince us that it's
irony it's satirical you shouldn't take
it seriously no it's really making fan
of that uh uh uh for young upper class
kids uh part of seul gangam and all the
irony there and so on but I claim
precisely this is what makes the song an
example of ideology how as I always
repeat how cism functions today I
believe in it it's all the time fun
making fun of itself but the magic is
that it
functions you see my point I'm not
claiming there is just the stupid song
with this Rave dance repetitive almost
military style the crowd follows this
religious Rave experience it's not just
this that makes it ideology it's
precisely this more of making fun of
yourself ironic distance and so on and
so on it's the same as my old thesis did
we use it Matthew in some of the films
I'm not sure or that stupid movie Kung
Fu Panda where I claim it's exemplary of
ideology today
why
because I had the misfortune of seeing
it four four times with the same above
mentioned son where uh for uh uh like on
the one hand the movie mobilizes all
this orientalist mythology you know uh
uh Kung Fu Destiny Warrior chosen
whatever the one and at the same time it
makes fun of its own ideology all the
time in kind of a common sensical
mocking of all the Buddhist or whatever
orientalist spiritual wisdoms but again
you shouldn't miss the point which is
that in spite of or I would rather have
said precisely because of all this self
mocking it works in the sense that far
from undermining all this orientalist uh
mythology in a strange way making fun of
V makes this ideology viable it is as if
the procedure since I am I hope here
with people who like at least some
movies films it's something that was
done in an intelligent way I claim with
in I don't like too much the film but
this aspect I like Lars font I hope you
saw it Breaking the
Waves uh he last fer himself has a
wonderful explanation where he says the
story in itself he says is ridiculously
melodramatic and if the form of the film
were to fit to be adequate to
the ridiculous melodramatic style of the
narrative it would have been inedible
how do you call it ridiculous so he says
that's why he opted you may remember it
if you saw the film for this uh quasi
documentary handheld camera shortcuts
and so on a style which is totally out
of sync with the mega romantic narrative
he said very nicely that this quasa
documentary style functions like some
kind of a
screen which softens and makes palpable
so that you can take so that you can
take seriously the story The reason I
like this is that what font Trier does
there is the exact opposite of the
standard melodramatic procedure where
the style is often more pathetic
emotional than the content I mean all
good analysts know this how often even
something that at least in classical
melodramas that you cannot directly depi
depict at the narrative level you
signally through the over pathetic
character of the style here is the exact
opposite it's the story which is
ridiculously pathetic you need this
filter as it were distantiated filter to
make the story palpable and I claim
again the same goes for this uh Gangnam
Style first and I think I'm not uh I
mean it quite
seriously uh when I say that this is the
way the mode of today's spiritual
experience if you if you want I'm not
making fun of it my claim is not it's AO
spiritual experience of course I find it
disgusting but uh my thesis underlying
thesis is much more radical it's uh that
uh what if a spiritual experience itself
can be disgusting even if it's authentic
I mean why do we automatically
associate inner spiritual experience
with something I don't know uh morally
elevating and so on and so on my idea
was always for example when I read their
horrible reading of course Nazi or other
Memoirs what if
there why automatically if someone does
something horrible in real life organize
murder torture and so on why do we
automatically assume that he he must be
somehow non-authentic hypocritical in
his inner life this is I know very sad
news pessimist news but I'm more and
more convinced of it now let me present
you as part of this line of thought
another experience which brought me a
lot of hatred in my own country already
I developed this in some of my books
where I proposed the line of like no
ethnic cleansing without
poetry literally you know why I took
this path because I got a little bit
tired with this eternal motive which you
find from levinas to adoro all of them
or even many General generally people of
culture of blaming us philosophers you
know the idea is political
totalitarianism for example Emanuel
levinas says this clearly political to
arianism is grounded in philosophical
notion of totality you think you have
access to Total absolute knowledge you
know totality and this justifies you
then to brutally impose your vision on
reality uh I claim okay maybe although I
doubt it deeply deeply because if you
look closely now at a naive empirical
level even if you if you look closely at
most of uh not even most of actual
so-called
totalitarianisms you will see that the
spontaneous
ideology of totalitarianism is always
historicist relativism you know for
example if there was someone who was not
philosophically totalitarian it's Adolf
Hitler read mamp it's a horrible book
pretty boring but it's worth reading you
see that his attitude was not man master
of un Universe his his attitude what man
is just a tiny dust of nature we are
totally exposed to Nature we will perish
disappear and so on it's total
historicist relativism and so on and so
on so what I'm saying is then U why even
I had some problems with uh even
with theorist theorists of the
construction who all Al claimed that
it's kind of a metaphysics of identity
sticking to absolute values again in
some way grounds totalitarianism and so
on now look for example at the time of
the French Revolution and you will see
that the Defenders of Anan regime were
historicists they claim we have you know
their line was the one of how is he
called the Great critic of French
Revolution Edmund B Burke or
who Burke yeah yeah you know the idea is
we all live within a certain particular
tradition which is ultimately contingent
but the worst thing we can do is to just
uh relativize this tradition which is
contingent and impose some Eternal
values and so on it was the
revolutionaries who were much more
metaphysical in the sense that no there
are natural rights of men if anything
the conflict between and partisans of
French Revolution was a conflict between
a
historicist and kind of absolutist no
Eternal values natural rights and so on
here I think it's a nice example of how
precisely the reference to an absolute
can open up the space of freedom but let
me go on with this idea ethnic cleansing
and so on let me be serious now I'm not
crazy don't be afraid I mean there are
poets who really are poets they are
absolute I mean but not so many as
people think like I don't know in the
20th century if you mention I don't know
Paul Salan or whatever but did you
notice nonetheless how many of
undoubtedly great modernist poets were
pretty close to Fascism or whatever
Elliot where what is my trauma here this
one uh if you it's very simple uh line
of thought if you we are basically half
decent people I already developed it I
think the first evening there and it's
difficult for us to kill someone and so
on so you need some kind of absolute
Mythic poetic religious Vision again to
function as a as a screen to make it
possible here I agree partially not
totally I'm not part of that today's
materialism of of of haris and Hitchens
and so on but uh I basically agree with
what uh Steven Weinberg I think said
somewhere that without religion bad
people would be doing bad thing and good
people good things you need something
like religion to make good people do bad
things I can tell you that this is what
happened in my own country for example
you know the story ex Yugoslavia ethnic
cleansing and so on I think it's not an
accident a chance that the leader of
Bosnian serbs is radan karajic a poet
and I'm not blaming just the serbs if
you look at other ex-yugoslav republics
Every Nation had its own karajic you
need this type of of a vis of a
vision to enable you to do the horrors
what do I mean by this it's interesting
to read I always quoted what Henry
himler you know the SS
boss uh he confronted this
problem like
uh he knew very well it's interesting to
read him he knew very well that SS
officers and soldiers were obliged to do
horrible thing while doing uh while
organizing Holocaust uh uh uh bringing
together all the Jews you had to beat
children women and so on and so on and
his problem was how
to how to enable German soldiers or SS
the elite to soldiers to do this without
as he himself put it himler without
becoming beasts
like beasts in the sense of Simply
enjoying getting involved in what they
are doing you maybe know what his
solution was bhavat Gita Oriental wisdom
himler always had in his pocket uh a
special leatherbound version of Bhagavad
Gita of course his Focus was you must
know Bhagavad Gita that famous encounter
between Arjuna the warrior and God
Krishna no in just before the big battle
Arjuna is on the battlefield with tens
of thousands of soldiers opposing Army
and has doubts my god do I have the
right to order the attack thousands will
die and so on all the suffering and then
God basically gives him a nice lesson of
this famous act without being fully
involved no and of this what we in the
west identify that's another Point does
does it really hold or not as Oriental
ontology he says but material reality
are just appearances it things grow
disintegrate disappear the true reality
is the reality of the your Eternal self
Atman which is eternal so The Logical
conclusion don't worry do all the
killing and so on what you can destroy
it's already in itself negligable
deserves to perish and so on and so on
and precisely again uh don't get
involved
and it's really shocking how if you look
for example I made the test and looked
also at Rwanda of course there is a poet
there who for 10 years was laying the
ground the foundation for for uh tsis
killing the hus and so on and so on
uh I'm not far from condemning poetry I
think that precisely authentic poetry is
the best medicine against this for under
mining National meats and so on and so
on but again I think that
precisely uh how you put it uh I don't
believe in cynicism in the sense of that
people can be totally cynical I claim
that nobody can be totally cynical each
of us has his or her or their own small
island of authenticity as it were you
know and uh here again poetry poetry is
needed you know where poetry
enters ideological poetry of
course the most terrifying trick of this
poetic justification of violence is a
very specific one Hitler sorry himler
also knew it it's they admit for example
let's go back to that situation that I
evoked the first evening here using you
Matthew I think as the example
let's say I am ordered to kill you okay
unfortunately I'm not perfect I will
have some problems no uh but then the
the trick
is a good totalitarian propaganda not
propaganda mythology admits this trouble
of mine of course we have most of us at
least some basic decency it's disgusting
difficult for us simply to approach
another guy pick out his eyes cut off of
his testicles whatever but then you know
what does it do authentic totalitarian
poetry it uh it redefines your very
problem with doing this as an as a
ethical problem Temptation in the sense
of as himler said most of the people can
do great things for their country even
sacrifice their lives a true hero
is the one who is ready to lose his soul
for the country to to do horrible things
for his Fatherland so you know like if I
have sorry don't take it personally it's
just history if I have to torture and
kill you the trick would come been to
say of course you feel horrible but the
true greatness is to is to elevate
yourself about this temptation of
ordinary Humanity precisely what you in
your everyday awareness experience as
ethically problematic is the weakness a
true hero a true ethical greatness is
when for a higher cost you are ready to
act Beyond good at evil and so on and so
on and
here you need some poetic Vision I
cannot call it
otherwise vision of I don't know
National Destiny religion call it
whatever you want to make them to make
them uh do that okay so again this would
be my first pessimist uh lesson of how
and at the end I will come to Buddhism
again which I already mentioned the
first precisely because I think that
here and I spoke with many Buddhists and
even mostly they agreed that here there
is a problem in buddhis namely
that
uh the really thing for us to admit is
that there is a there is no necessary
inner link between ordinary
goodness towards others doing kind
things and so on and let's call it
navely authentic authentic spiritual
experience maybe you know the story
which I like to repeat I'm sorry if you
know it I wrote about it long ago 20
years ago in a book A book I I mean I
wrote about a book which I like very
much by alos haxley maybe you know it
the great Eminence linon Greece it's a
biography of Father Joseph per Joseph
who was a priest and the right hand of
cardinal rier the de facto ruler of
France during the 30 Years
War uh in the early uh 17th century uh
and uh you know what is so crazy about
this guy if there ever was an evil
politician it's Father
Joseph to cut a long story short if we
engage in some mythical genealogy and
try to guess uh what's the origin of
Hitler of World War II it's Father
Joseph you know why this was the battle
between Catholics Protestants for Europe
but Cardinal rier had no Illusions he
knew it's not really about that it is
about guaranteeing Central about
establishing Central role of France in
European politics and the way to do it
is to prevent German
unification and
so Father Joseph who executed this plan
did something totally unprincipled he
although this was officially a war of
Catholics against Protestants he made a
PCT with Swedish Protestants against
against uh Austrian Catholics just to
keep Germany uh divided and this is the
logic I was referring to because Germany
was divided because Germany constituted
itself as a nation state too late
everybody knows that this delay cost
first world war and then it's the
ultimate cause and then of second world
war but what I like me say that okay
here we have a guy who was at this level
really really evil organizing murders
extortions torture name it now comes the
horrible thing at the same time this
guy wrote was in a permanent
communication exchanging letters with
some uh uh Nary women's Convent how you
call it and and uh he wrote them the
most authentic beautiful uh mystical
Reflections at the top level name it
like who are the big hits s Teresa or
John of the Cross it's at that level
it's absolutely authentic spirituality
and that's what it's not a really great
book but this is the nice point they
this is what bothers so much alos hle
how can a guy who is doing all this at
the same time how can
he write something that you cannot but
say if you're honest my God this is the
Pearl the thing itself this is it and we
can go on here like uh
uh Henri hyri you know we are back to
himler his second man who organized the
van conference Holocaust I read I was
quite traumatized I read in a biography
of no biography sorry history of ss that
hyri was of course German Elite
relatively educated U privately he
played very well violin and in the
evenings he used to gather with his SS
friends and they have some kind of
amateur constituted string quartet and
they like to play what is my God
unfortunately as I must tell you is
generally admitted one of the top
achievements of western music late
betoven string quartets now I found this
to be some kind of let me call it
ontological Scandal you know like how is
this possible this is not just that the
not even scum totally evil man like hyri
you know again the one who organized
plant
Holocaust
can maybe authentically enjoy appreciate
such beautiful
music because here I want to resist the
temptation which hxy was not able to
resist his solution is this only can
mean that Christian or Catholic
spirituality is not authentic
he didn't want to admit that you can
have it both together so this is why as
you maybe know he moved towards the Far
East no meditation Buddhism and so on
thinking that his idea was this one that
Christianity is too much focused on
suffering of following the path of
Christ identifying with suffering that
this makes it potentially pathological
while this more
peaceful withdrawn Oriental spiritual
attitude can do the job better we here I
have another bad news for you I always
like to mention this book I hope some of
you know it uh Brian Victoria who is
himself a Zen Buddhist monk you really
should read this book it's called Zen at
War it's a you can find it I think it's
reprinted all the time it's widely uh
debated in than in generally Buddhist
circles it's not a big theoretical book
it does something very modest it looks
in detail on how the Japanese Zen
Community they were relatively strong I
think around 10 Millions more related to
Japanese Imperial War Conquest uh first
war with China then World War I in in
the 1930s and 40s and the result is
pretty depressive not only they
tolerated it but apart from literally
five or 10 dissidents they
unanimously supported the war not even
this but even provided
tools like advices to make war more
efficient for example now I will be
really evil I'm sorry if you already
know the story do you remember if you
are old enough some of you are most
happy for you not in the old Hipp times
he was very popular who is he D Taro
Suzuki DT Suzuki you know the great gen
popularizer what people tend to forget
but he was honest enough to admit this
he never denied it that in the 1930s and
40s early 40s he
was totally supporting Japanese military
Imperial politics and not only this but
even uh gave active advices about how to
render it more efficient for example I
quote this I forgot which one in two
three of my books this wonderful passage
from Suzuki where he says again it's the
same problem as I mentioned before like
imagine yourself in battle you confront
your
enemy you see him and of course you
cannot avoid a minimum of let's call it
personalization like you are sorry
Matthew it's always whom I think when I
think let's kill a person I think about
you don't ask me why like you know you
are a human being you have a child all
these
problems Suzuki has an answer here it's
pretty horrifying he says these problems
remain as long as we remain stuck into
this what Buddhism describes as this
samsara the will of Desire false
identity when we uh perceive falsely our
self as agent with a substantial self
you know when we don't fully assume this
logic of in Indian anatman there is no
self just void and so on he says that
let's say I have a knife I want to stab
you if I'm still caught in the world of
Illusion I will find it problematic like
my God I am stabbing you what right do I
have to do it but Suzuki says imagine
that I go through Buddhist Enlightenment
then I really assume that I have no self
I'm just a kind of totally impassive
transparent Observer and the world also
reality loses it its substantial weight
and becomes just a dance of phenomena
popping up here disappearing there and
then he says if you really
assume this existential experience then
it becomes much easier he Suzuki
provides a wonderful the says it's no
longer me deciding to stab you it is as
he says a knife in my hand as part of a
cosmic dance is moving in space and as
part of the same dance mat sorry you
your body hits my knife and time for
nothing in it you know I'm just this
totally enlightened Observer and so on
and so on now
let's avoid a misunderstanding here I'm
not saying saying I have immense respect
for Buddhism I'm not saying whooo
Buddhism theory of Japanese militarism
or whatever then I'm saying and Suzuki
after the war was heroic enough to admit
it what I'm saying is that uh is that uh
it doesn't matter it's
neutral Suzuki says this wonderfully in
a people just ignored this when they
bought this you know Buddhism
holistic organic you are gentle with
nature no he says Buddhism is a
technique of meditation you can be a
fascist a torturer a Democrat a liberal
whatever communist it doesn't matter he
I found this really radical and great
this is a very traumatic thing to do he
admitted accepted this irreducible Gap
you can have your
inner authentic inner experience ience
it absolutely doesn't guarantee that you
will not be doing horrible things in
reality in some conditions as Suzuki
admits it it may even make it easier
because again the moment you don't
perceive yourself as agent you are no
longer fully uh fully identified uh with
it and so on and so on uh so here I have
a more General problem about where we
are
today here I have a problem with my
personal friend but we have some
theoretical conflicts Judith Butler I
don't know if I mentioned this I
appreciate her very much but not the
usual books which are more her for
example the books that I like by her is
her first book subjects of desire which
is I think a very good reading of Hegel
that's what I appreciate in her she's
really deep in her heart a hegelian and
once she told me slavo you must really
hate me I said no you may be evil but
you like Hegel somebody who wrote Such a
book on Hegel cannot be totally evil
then we Embrace yeah yeah we were
friends and the other book the psychic
life of power these are I think her best
works not the big official stuff my
problem with her is this one her General
space and I don't care here if she
really meant it like that I'm speaking
about how she P perceived is that the
enemy quot Mar the opponent is this
patriarchal
identity whatever and then what she's
fighting for is to undermine patriarchal
identity essentialism whatever you want
and to assert that even our most
intimate sexual identity is just a a
result of you know the story of this uh
uh
uh symbolic performative rituals which
also allow then a space of maneuver when
you ironically repeat rituals in a
displaced way you gain a distance you
can undermine them a little bit my
problem here is
what it's not the time defending
patriarchy Identity or what it's okay
nice but what is she describing I claim
she's simply describing the predominant
ideology
today I don't think our societies today
still require this standard patriarchal
uh
identity attitude you know like each of
us has an eternal essential nature or
whatever and so on what she is attacking
all the time I think that
precisely what is predominant ideology
telling us it's what I like to call this
enlightened Wern Buddhism you know
Society is no longer telling us
sacrifice yourself for a higher cause or
what Society is telling us something
like uh be truly yourself be authentic
experiment create yourself don't get
stuck in one
identity experiment restruct uh
reconstruct yourself all the time and
again all this is spiced with some kind
of
spontaneous pseo Buddhism where the idea
is don't get too attached to it you know
don't assume fully any identity always
play Dance then you get all this new age
remember things are not really
serious it's a cosmic dance or whatever
you want and so on and so on so again uh
uh let me go now back this is the reason
I began with uh Gangam Style because I
think think that
uh this type of cynical working where
you do
something but you think it redeems you
if you do it with irony with
distance I don't accept this I claim
that again as I already said that
precisely ironic distance helps you to
swallow it I mean this is also part of
my personal experience where I remember
when I was young living in a a socialist
country uh you know there was one
wonderful rumor which is of course wrong
for theoretical reasons but there is a
moment of truth in it all the time there
was a rumor and then I heard from
friends that there was the same rumor in
Soviet Union and so on that you know we
lived for political jokes this was the
big thing there and I think if you ask
me seriously I mean it that uh the
greatest spiritual loss of the fall of
Communism was the loss of good political
jokes they simply disappeared they were
absolutely Sublime intelligent wonderful
even this I will not bore them with
those joke even this what Freud's claim
Freud claims that it's a specificity of
Central Europe this wonderful two level
jokes you know a joke is told you think
that's it but then there is another
twist so uh the rumor was that there is
somewhere in the secret police or
Central Committee of the party a special
secret department where they produce
jokes against themselves to keep people
satisfied the idea was if you provide
this you know jokes making uh making
people uh this you know it doesn't cost
anything you give people this false
relaxation freedom and so and so on I
don't think this works for a very simple
theoretical reason because you know how
jokes function jokes are by definition
they're a very mysterious thing they
never have an author like you know how
do you tell a joke you tell it always by
oh do you know the joke I heard the joke
some something in the functioning of a
joke prohibits prevents you to say now
an idea came me I just invented a joke
it should be some Anonymous other
Anonymous you're always just you're
always just telling jokes so again I
think this is wrong but again even if
it's spontaneous I think jokes
definitely played this
role this role of uh making it viable
tolerable for you to live in such a
societ
I'm so attached to this because you know
in the last years under communism when
Communists were able to read the writing
on the wall that their time is over to
enhance their popularity some communist
politicians it was Madness
wonderful started themselves to tell
jokes about
themselves I mean even rean rean Ron Dr
came close to it but didn't go to the
end in this I think I remember a croat
politician visited it was late 70s
visited Rome and then come back and when
people expected this kind of official
report on friendship between Yugoslav
and Italian people whatever he started
to tell jokes against himself you know
which were not very funny but pretty
nice like he made fun of him himself as
stupid and non-educated you know the
idea was for example it plays on you
know this in Europe at least ambiguity
of the word chapel chapel can mean the
church chapel and also we call it in
Italian capella you know the small band
which plays in cafeteras in restaurants
no and the guy said you know I got lost
in Rome uh I was told that I should go
and see you know Michelangelo Vatican
cistin chapel and I look in all
cafeteras and nowhere was cistin Chapel
playing and then it goes on like I was
then told to go to see Marriage of
Figaro I looked checked all the churches
nowhere was the marriage of figuro
announced and then it goes on you know
the German City Baden Baden no this is a
standard communist joke that our
politician travels on a train through
Germany and says oh what city is this
and the guy tells him Baden Baden and he
says I'm not an idiot you don't have to
tell me two times or whatever and so but
again this is my link with Kung Fu Panda
how you shouldn't
be deluded here this very distance makes
it uh uh makes it viable uh so okay back
to Gangam Style this stupid Rhythm and
at the same time with this uh Stupid
written nonetheless something like let's
call it uh uh religious experience
religious experience kept at a distance
but precisely sustained through this uh
distance uh if we pursue this line of
thought I would like to propose when
people ask me can you think about an
authentic religious film of Hollywood I
have an answer it's not not uh uh Mel
Gibson uh passion which is I think as
everyone know the greatest Triumph of
sad Mao uh uh
gay orientation in Hollywood you know
you have male naked body tortured for
two hours much more do you want it's uh
it's did you see
it I really think it's
again I mean it seriously but precisely
critically toward spiritual experience
did you see Project
X it was half a year ago a year
ago a modest film about uh in a small
American town a group of three uh three
nerds non-popular guys who decide to
organize a party because father and
mother are going somewhere for the
weekend and father gives to the son
Specific Instructions don't touch the
car don't enter that room only five
friends and so on what happened is that
rumor starts to circulate and at the end
uh uh a couple of thousands of people
gather the house is burned down the car
is ruined everything and so on and so on
and it obviously at a certain point I
didn't want to Bor today but I think you
can even exactly locate it where you
enter the sacred Dimension it becomes a
sacred
event uh so what what I'm simply
claiming is
that with all Hollywood commercialism
and so on there is
more of an authentic sacred dimension in
this film than in most of the official
religion that's what I'm
claiming we absolutely have no right to
dismiss it as just manipul or whatever
you want consumerist manipulation and so
on and so on there is
another wonderful detail about this film
if you saw it at the very end father
returns home is of course
shocked and says to his son okay I you
will have to work for it to pay for it
but I must admit something I didn't
expect you are strong enough to do
something like this and so on and so on
and this is crucial this is how uh
uh how uh uh laon explains the role of
the
father precisely of the traditional
patriarchal father he says I
quote I think it's from somewhere in
seminary 11 uh beyond the mother stands
out the image of a
father who would turn a blind eye to
desires this marks the true function of
the father which is fundamentally to
unite and not to oppose a desire to the
law you know where I got the same idea
although it's a feminine figure I read
in a book on Katherine the Great that
one of her Elder the Russian Empress one
of her Elder servants told her do you
know that your other servants are behind
your back stealing uh expensive wines
and expensive food uh from your reserves
and he said I know this but this is how
I keep them satisfied but you know this
is lon's idea that the the fun you know
how you relate to a traditional paternal
Authority it's always a minimally naive
Authority farther up there prohibit
things but then you find the blind
spots where you are as it were
not on Father's father's radar or
whatever and you can there transgress
things and so on but for laon this
precisely is the function of paternal
authority to precisely it's never a
total Authority it
precisely doesn't see everything and
allows for this islands of transgression
where you can enjoy and so on and so on
in this sense if some of you are
philosophers laon had a good critical
point
about critical point about Hegel you
know the famous hegelian dialectics of
Master and servant where hegel's idea is
the master enjoys the servant works for
the Master's enjoyment lon's point is
not the opposite one the only one who
can who can enjoy a little bit is the
servant with this small islands where
he's out of the father's View and of
course okay we can go on here because
lon's point is precisely that when
father no longer plays this role of an
authority which prohibits but
nonetheless you know leaves you open
space for small transgressions and so
on then you get something much more
horrible you get the postmodern
permissive father who no longer
prohibits enjoyment but it it's actually
imposing it on you you know the style of
sex is healthy did you do it blah blah
blah which is I think something much
more terrifying is the way to render you
impotent literally this is clinically
true psychoanalytic friends are telling
me the problem is not the father who is
moderately oppressive that's wonderful a
moderately oppressive father gives you
the space to resist it is the problem is
and my God I will know do something
obscene I will admit that I had this
experience with my father the problem
when I returned from high school home
father told me where are the girls are
you a man did you do it do and then he
said my father the most horrible thing
is it that you cannot do it do you need
my advice or what absolute nightmare or
whatever okay this incidentally is also
why I'm horrified by today's attitude to
Works
uh sex and other Pleasures which is more
and more not what I'm tempted to call an
authentic consumerism which would be
smoke take drugs ores to the end but
this kind of a reasonable Hedonism you
know do it but in a proper way in a
healthy way don't go too far and so on
and so on like when I flew two months
ago across the Atlantic I found in
hemisphere SP the Journal of United
Airlines one of the most depressing
texts that I can imagine it was
celebrating sex but you know in what way
like sex is healthy they claimed if you
make laugh often love it's good for your
heart for blood circulation it's good
for your muscles then
even it becomes so obscene at the end
where the text says even kissing deep
frch kissing it's very good it keeps the
muscle strong so when you will be old
the saliva will not be dropping for it's
nightmare it's nightmare this type of
stuff so okay let me go on
here uh uh what I'm saying here and here
I locate myself into the Jude Christian
Tradition now no what I'm saying is
that uh this is now referring to this
sacred experim es of like uh like
Project X of this Collective
transgressive orgastic violence whatever
uh the deepest Insight already in Jewish
tradition is that
uh is that this is what Lon would have
put it the Living God the god of the
real which is extremely this exper
experience of sacred as this kind of a
pagan total violence sacred orgy this is
what the Jewish tradition tries to keep
at a certain distance no which is why
Jewish god in a way is a is a dead God
here I agree although otherwise I'm very
opposed to him with Emanuel levinas who
says somewhere something pretty
surprising and shocking he says that the
ultimate address of the biblical
commandment don't kill is God
himself you know uh uh in other words
whole the whole of Judaism should be
read as a temptation to not to come to
close to God or not to allow God to come
too close for us and leidas provides
because then it's murderous violence for
example you know in it's from Exodus
4:24 to 26 the sin which grounds uh
circumcision you remember how brutally V
Moses is in a tent with his wife and
simply God as an anonymous dark stranger
enters and wants to kill Moses and then
the wife of Moses quickly cuts the skin
of the sun to protect her but this idea
that when God comes too close it's uh
it's brutality which is why I think uh
in what sense do I mean this one of the
common places with which I totally
disagree is that
uh outtz means the Dead the death of God
like you know the usual logic how could
God have allowed something like this to
happen but uh I claim here I agree with
habas who says somewhere that it's much
more
ambiguous when when you have a truly
terrifying event like awit and we can
give other examples of course from Congo
to gulak or whatever uh there is
something obscene in claiming oh this is
just human evil human causality the evil
is so
terrifying that we cannot but call it
Divine and divine here means simply the
excessive Sublime strength of
it so in other words I don't agree with
a famous book I forgot the author of on
Holocaust where the title of the book is
God died in awit no I claim God but God
of the real this
murderous absolutely destroying God he
came alive in aitz and the problem is
how to keep how to keep this God at a
distance
here Judaism has a wonderful ful
solution I quot it here a couple of
times I hope you know it there are in
Babylonian talmud and in some other
parts there is a story which is repeated
a couple of times which is I think an
absolutely wonderful theological story
it will sound as a joke but I checked
with my Jewish friends this is talmud
sacred text it's basically uh referring
to one of your compatriots uh Marshall
mcluen it's the Marshall mclan moment in
any Hall you remember two
guys Woody Allen and another fighting
about mcan's Theory and then what all of
us dream happens mcluen comes and says
to Woody Allen you are right that guy is
total
idiot it's literally the same scene to
distinguish this is the story from
talmud two distinguished rabbis debate a
theological point
and the one who is losing the
debate says wait a minute let's call
Jehovah God to come and decide and
Jehovah
comes old man comes there and then the
other the winning in the debate Rabbi
starts to shout and God basically he
tells God you did your job you didn't do
a very good job the universe is not
perfect but you did your job
now your time is out leave us
intelligent people to debate what you
did you don't have anything to say here
and that's the beauty uh that uh God's
reaction is oh my God you are right and
God runs away I mean it's I know this
story is often used in a not proper way
signaling that Jews are by natural de ma
Democratic that this is the origin of
democracy or whatever know but it's
nonetheless a a wonderful story where
again the point is how to keep God at a
how to keep God at a distance let me now
uh uh so this would be one dimension
which I claim will be and is returning
more and more violently in our uh
violently in our
experience this uh obscene domain of the
Sacred which we don't want to
acknowledge it but I think it's crucial
to acknowledge it if you look from for
the experience of sacred today you find
it in Project X more than in religions
and so on but again it doesn't mean that
I like Project X it means that uh I
don't think that there is something
automatically ethically Noble in the
experience of of the Sacred s already in
Antiquity they knew it you know like let
me mention the best known example aides
bantes or you know that game where you
have also an explosion of murderous
violence of women now I think this
theory is not
necessarily anti-feminist I was always
very suspicious of the attempts to
ground
feminism in any kind of feminine
Divinity great mother or whatever I
think if anything it's the opposite that
usually the price for this elevation of
Mother Earth or whatever goddess is
usually paid by paid by real women like
I remember years ago I read the
description of some I think new guine
I'm not sure where tribe which was
apparently
very feminist in the sense that the
goddess the supreme god was a goddess
and even to be primitive the way their
Village was structured the central
Temple had a kind of a vague vagina for
them and around where the houses there
was only one problem of course actual
women of their pride were prohibited to
enter that vagina only men could enter
it and so on so what I want to say I
want want to give you here another
example of today's
ideology it's really a terrifying one uh
North
Korea we don't trust the media no no
don't be afraid I'm not saying it's
really a great Democratic regime or what
no I'm saying is that it's there was a
book recently published a little bit
naive is the book but it's interesting
because it does nonetheless it's a
correct report I think on the of the
state of think something that you know
the usual thing we read about North
Korea is that that the regime can
survive because of this old Confucian
ethics uh paternal Authority obedience
and so on and so on no this book I think
conclusively demonstrates that this is
totally
false the idea is that this guy did
something interesting he really how he
succeeded years ago he was allowed to
stay there now of course he cannot enter
North Korea anymore
he looked at not International North
Korean propaganda but at what or rather
how
Korean propaganda works at the local
level for their own people what's the
message there and he discovered some
very weird things that first the central
metaphor for the party and the leader is
Mother not
father he claims that it's simple Mist
transation where it's translated like
Kim Kim yongil or whatever the father of
the nation and so on no the term used in
Korean and so the book claims it's it's
the head of the family but usually in
everyday language it means mother and
then this book has some wonderful
obscene details about how this works for
example it's really a wonderful proof
this book takes the latest edition of
North Korean dictionary dictionary of
North Korean language and looks at two
entries mother father the entry of for
mother is over one page it begins with
Mother first meaning the biological
mother he gives birth to a child then
mother as the family who takes care of
the children object of Love blah blah
then of course the third meaning mother
in the sense of a social Force which
takes care of all the people like the
example here is Korean Workers Party is
the mother like mother to Korean people
and all that it's over one page then you
look at the entry father it's one
sentence father is the partner of the
mother
like and then he goes on and looks at
official songs of party songs and claims
that the most popular official party
song it's extremely obscene if you read
it is a song celebrating the party as
mother and all the time
openly mentioning mother's breasts like
oh uh oh Korean party our mother we suck
all that we need food love from your
breasts we will never abandon your
breasts we will always cling to your
breasts it's pure obscenity and so on
then this goes even further did you
notice if you saw some of these official
photos of kimil
kimyong how the official photos don't
try to you know the stalinist were
specialist in how to call it R changing
the photo to make leader look younger
that uh first they all have a stomach
and clear feminine features kimyong
kimil the father and the crazy son uh
now it's interesting what is now
happening this is a very strange move
that all of a sudden the leader is
publicly married the third one now you
know they show because kimon kill they
even claim It's a Wonderful reading how
uh how you remember maybe you saw it
sometimes in newspaper the photo of
kimyong ill the second leader how his
hair is like waving and he has some kind
of a plastic jacket and and he proves
with other photos that he consciously
imitates the image of ordinary Korean
mother who has this cheap jacket has to
stand in line take care of the family
and so on and so on and so
on uh don't misunderstand me here I'm
not playing any type of Defense of
patriarchal Authority in the sense of ah
you overthrow patriarchy you get even
worse you know like as if give power to
feminist and you end up in North Korea
no men are still absolutely in power
there my point is precisely that we must
this thing radically
separate feminist issues feminine
emancipation from all this of
society as a mother and so on and so on
this is why I did something that some
people took for a little bit crazy I
claim that maybe the time is to
more emphasize what already frud did at
some point uh the distinction woman
mother that
psychoanalysis does absolutely does not
claim what it's usually attributed to it
you know that mother is uh uh that woman
doesn't have penis so she gets a child
who functions as a symbolic substitute
all that no that precisely uh
um uh authentic feminine subjectivity
means Med to catalon story short no I
was always fascinated by Meda I think
far from being the horrible destructive
woman whatever Meda is My Heroine I
think maybe the time has come to pass
from from antigona to Meda I'm a little
bit tired of that celebration of antigon
whatever no okay but uh let me go on so
again
uh you know uh we what I'm trying to
tell you is this of course a certain
traditional patriarchal IDE ideology is
dis integrated but what we are getting
is not authentic emancipation but we are
getting one totalitarian version would
have been North
Korea society as mother embodied the
other version would have been this new
say sense of sacredness and so on and so
on and I
claim that uh here the predominant
version today this is my prediction that
the future lies with Buddhism but I'm
critical about it it's not so much
authentic Buddhism as a kind of a
popular Western Buddhism now I will just
slowly recapitulate what I already said
two days ago but I will move further
namely I I think that there
are
two reasons at least why Buddhism
fits by Buddhism I will not go into this
is it authentic or not of course
authentic Buddhism is
something great incredibly radical and
so on what I mean so yeah time what I
mean is something else what I mean is
that
uh we should ask this simple question we
are entering a new era global capitalism
and so on it's a very traditional
Marxist question what type of
spirituality
self-experience ideological self-
understanding fits perfectly today's
capitalism I think that Buddhism can do
the job much better than Christianity
first because let's put it very simply
on the one
hand what defines today's universe is
the crazy Global
capitalist
Dynamics and as many people pointed
out uh
it is uh much
uh it's uh you know I was always
fascinated when you read this propaganda
leaflets whatever which try to convince
you to take a course in Transcendental
Meditation whatever how the message is
always a double message the first
message is we live in a crazy world we
crave for material goods and and so on
this is a false world we are losing our
true self so don't we need time to
Simply step out of this crazy dance of
hyperactivity to find simple inner truth
inner peace and so on and so on but
always always then you find a second
paragraph which is much more cynical and
which tells you something like in this
way with a proper inner peace and
distance you will function even better
on the market you know it always you
know who began this it's not even us in
the west I read somewhere that after the
end of the World War II Japanese defeat
Suzuki established the same Suzuki the
first
business the first Zen course for
businessmen in Tokyo in
47 this idea
that if you are minimally enlightened
like to be vulgar aware that the reality
we confront is not the substantial real
reality that the ultimate truth is the
void you arrive at this through this
meditative distance and so on and so on
that precisely by not the idea is the
following one if you take crazy this
game of uh imagine being a stock broker
or whatever speculating with Futures and
hedge funds whatever I mean if you take
this game seriously you get crazy it's
so Dynamic you know like a rumor starts
can ruin the whole industry whatever and
the idea is that the only way to survive
it if you learn some kind
of inner distance inner peace and so on
telling yourself but I'm not really
there I quite as I put it in one of my
books I think that we all know Max
Weber's classical book know the the
Protestant ethics and the spirit of
capitalism I think that if Weber were to
be alive today he would have written a
book something like T is ethics and the
spirit of global capitalism it fits much
better uh uh do you know that I quot it
at the very end I'm not sure I think
it's of my tickly subject but I'm not
sure a wonderful documentary where you
have some sociologist like SAS assassin
and some Tibetan Buddhists and they
claim that the only way to account
ontologically for the crazy experience
of reality which is proper to today's
capitalism this total fragility like
remember 2008 the you know you think you
live in a stable world all you know this
fragility all of a sudden reality we
know it can dissolve and so on is to
accept some kind of Buddhist onology of
there is no substantial reality just
phenomena dancing and so on and so on so
this is I think uh the first reason why
uh uh why Buddhism can function much
better than Western Christian traditions
in enabling us to survive at everyday
level survive through a
distance the the this crazy Dynamic
logic of global capitalism the second
thing I think is precisely the great
Revolution that we are approaching the
uh biogenetic Revolution I already also
mentioned this two days ago what
fascinates me is that I really think
that maybe even the very definition of
Being Human will change because what
does it mean now for us to be human
minimally it means I'm a thinking being
among other things no it means I'm in
here reality is out there I can think
whatever I want on and so on and as we
all know the latest result
of brain Sciences but also practices and
so on is that slowly slowly we are not
yet there but this fundamental divide
between me my inside and outside is
breaking down in both directions you
know how from time to time you get all
these stories about how they can wire
your brain so that you can move object
objects directly you for example you
have wheelchairs for crippled people
where you don't even need that Steven
Hawkins finger you know you just think
strongly forward the because the chair
moves because again it's very simple
they already can decode your very
Elementary
orders to your muscles and they simply
read them and directly transmitted to
the machine the problem is rather for me
that it goes also the other way around
from inside outside that is to say uh I
was quite shocked and I spoke with some
people connected with it and they told
me it's not a joke namely that it's
quite serious you can check it on uh you
can uh uh uh check it on uh uh you can
check it on
uh uh sorry on on the net namely what
did you hear about uh did you hear about
DARPA project DARPA means defense
Advanced research projects agency it's
uh in United States uh uh big huge
military agency supporting
neuroscientific research and among other
things it's not a
joke they are now doing something
they call uh
uh uh narrative
analysis and uh I read their program
it's uh it's it's pretty pretty
terrifying they are not yet there but
the very project is straight the idea is
this one first it reads like some kind
of structural analysis they claim how to
prevent terrorist attacks we have to see
how the mind of terrorist works so at
the first level is
simply let's analyze all the discoursive
rhetorical strategies how do you how
does ideology create a terrorist what
short cuts short circuits rather in
their reasoning does it and so on then
comes the real thing they try to
identify parts of the brain which are
active in this processes when you assume
a fanatical belief and so on and the
idea they say it openly is
that we will be able to influence
someone to change his or her
beliefs not by arguing with him either
even brainwashing him but through
direct biogenetic
intervention and I think this is Quite A
New Perspective admitted that it's no
longer like it's no longer even
ideological struggle like you are a
terrorist I will not try to reason with
you you are wrong I will not try even to
brainwash you torture you I will simply
ask myself at the biological level what
goes on in your mind and intervene
there I mean okay again it's still not
yet developed but uh things are
developing here fast so what I'm saying
is
that
how how to accept
this that namely that this fundamental
divide between subject object my inner
life outer life you know that all even
all cognitivist admit that at least from
our experience there is a gap here on
the one hand you look at the brain
stupid piece of meat and so on
how you make a jump from there to your
inner
experience they're trying to do it at
some Elementary level they
already can do it so again the problem
is how do we react to this the problem
is if we accept this that Science and
Technology will succeed relatively soon
in this radical self objectivization
that our thinking processes emotional
reactions and so on will become
something which we will be able to
identify as neuronal processes in your
brain and then to influence it directly
like
that there are as I already said two
days ago there are the way I see three
four main reactions to this one is that
we in our immediate self experience are
condemned eternally
to live in this illusion that we are
free agents and so on you know that that
uh that we are wired biologically
evolutionary to experience ourselves as
free responsible
agents so in other words there is an
irreducible cognitive gap between
scientific truth which tells us that
there is no Free Will and so on by the
way I I'm not saying this is true I
don't agree with this and it's very
interesting do you know the guy you
should read him interesting called
Benjamin liet it's a neuroscientist from
Berkeley I think who
uh he already some 10 years or 20 years
ago uh proposed and did the experiment
which is usually referred to as the
ultimate experiment demonstrating that
there is not free will but interestingly
enough he himself disagrees with this
reading he claims no no the experiment
is the famous one you know to simplify
to the atmost you are asked to do some
Elementary gesture
like pick up this pen and move it here
or there whatever just to do it
immediately you decide you do it she
then of course wires put sensors on you
blah blah and what he did prove is that
a split of a second before you
decide your neurons already know
it in other words this allegedly proves
that uh when you do something freely in
the sense of you just on the spot decide
it you don't really decide you just
become aware of a process which
objectively is already going on before
and they are even further developing
this today for example they have proven
absolutely conclusively I like this that
when you go to a store to buy a car and
are nervous sweating what to buy and so
on they can tell you 10 minutes before
even that you you've already decided 7
to 10 minutes before and so on so okay
what's so interesting is that Benjamin
liet rejects this reading she claims
that yes it's a very hegelian argument I
like it his answer is that yes this
happens with our positive decisions but
that in that split of a
second when my neurons decide and I
don't yet know it I can block it that
our freedom is originally a freedom to
say no that our freedom is not to freely
decide for something but just for no
reason at all to sabotage okay this is a
complicated debate what I wanted to say
is that uh if we accept it which I don't
this idea that we are just wired
mechanisms our Free Will is an illusion
the first attitude this is the majority
standard opinion is to accept the Gap to
say okay we are forever condemned to
live in illusion because we are wired to
it we experience ourselves as free okay
then we can give a more philosophical
twist to this I will not go into into
theasian answer they have great debates
in Germany habas tries to play more of a
let's call it a transcendental game here
he claims that even if the result of our
scientific research is we are not free
we are Neal mechanisms how did we reach
this result through scientific analysis
scientific reasoning arguing which
precisely presupposed
that we are free thinking beings so the
idea is that even when you prove that
you are not free the space for this very
proof is sustained by the space of
reasoning and that you cannot close the
circle here that's another Point okay
then we have another tendency for
example Patricia and Paul Churchland who
claim but it's Utopia I don't think it
works who claim that
no there is nothing really Eternal
biological in our spontaneous self
perception as free agents they claim no
it is possible to change our in the same
way as for example I don't know when
something strikes today we no longer
experience it as divine intervention and
so on that we can imagine a society
where people fully integrate assume
scientific results we are not free
beings and so on and so on and it would
be they claim they try to pass to give
it a positive twist that it will be a
much more tolerant Society
less less moralistic less severe
punishment and so on simply to take this
into account but then my hero here okay
not hero but the most interesting guy I
claim is the German guy Thomas matching
matching
in his wonderful big fat book uh uh
being no one where he tries he first he
accepts this Gap he says that if you
look
at cognitivist theories which totally
naturalize our mind he says that we can
know it rationally but we cannot really
believe in it we cannot really accept it
there is a gap here but he provides an
exception again Buddhism he claims that
you see the parallel that if you go to
the end in Buddhist Enlightenment and if
you reach a Enlightenment
Nirvana where you get the point that you
have no
free that you are not a free agent you
are not a substantial self and so on all
that there is the only point where you
do reach a subjective position which is
compatible with the latest scientific
results it's a very beautiful reading
but as always I like to bring uh bad
news as always I claim there are
problems here so let me conclude just a
little bit with where do I see problems
here
uh uh uh first Buddhism is concerned
with solving the problem of suffering so
the first aom is always we don't want to
Suffer Well here already I have problems
I think if there is a point of
psychoanalysis is that uh we want to
suffer and it's
irreducible and uh I I think that uh I I
my first Association here is you know a
typical since we are here Cinema lovers
film Noir scene you know the typical
scene is like the kind of I don't know
who Robert mam Humphrey Bogard guy falls
for a evil F fatal and at the end he
loses everything he's totally ruined and
then somebody asks him now you know it
it was ruin so sad that you didn't know
this before to avoid it and his answer
the hero's answer is always uh uh is
always no it was worth even if I were to
know that it will end in ruined it it
was worth doing it this idea of it's a
catastrophe but I'm ready to do it again
so what I want to say is that uh uh my
first point is that Buddhism is here way
too optimistic in a way in this belief
you know that all living beings want to
get rid of suffering and so on I doubt
it second Point uh uh I think one of the
mystifications of our Western perception
of Buddhism is that we identify too much
with meditation in a very good book on
reality of Buddhism I read it's very
interesting that in countries like
Thailand blah blah buma where Myanmar
now where Buddhism is really a way of
life only a tiny minority
meditates it's not so much meditation is
more an ideal it's like to remind you
that
it is possible to reach but for a large
majority of people being a Buddhist
simply means don't cost too much
suffering and so on all that stuff all
that stuff uh okay but let's go on now
where I
see uh a problem with uh where I see a
problem with uh Buddhism again it's what
I already mentioned Buddhism begins with
suffering so then you slowly train
yourself ethically and so on at the end
you step out of this will of desire you
are no longer controlled by Karma your
acts no longer leave
traces you don't hurt other people and
so on and so on here I have a couple of
problems and okay I don't have time to
go now in detail in them but I had big
debates with Buddhist who at least maybe
they pretend that this I don't know
considered to me that there is a problem
here namely did you notice this radical
ambiguity in Buddhism how when they talk
about reaching
Enlightenment they oscillate between two
extremes on the one hand the idea is
Enlightenment is simply a radical shift
in your self experience Enlightenment
doesn't mean anything changes in the
world
it means just you radically shift your
attitude you no longer believe that you
are a substantial agent Free Will and so
on you know just this you accept the
void on the other hand you have a much
more radical tendency that living as
such is suffering and that
basically that's the idea of bodhisatwa
the Buddhist Saint who refuses to enter
near
Nirvana but although he entered Nirvana
he comes back to our illus reality he
postpones his own
salvation till all living sentient
beings will be saved and so on and so on
I think if you ask me the origin of all
the problems with Buddhism is batwa this
very Noble apparently idea of I could be
there could have been there in Nirvana
but I have such loving Sympathy For The
Suffering of all living beings that I
came back so that only we all together
should join it the problem here is uh I
think here already the battle is lost
because you know authentic Buddhism for
me means that in Nirvana you don't go
somewhere else you stay fully
here and you can even be active as
for an authentic radical
Buddhist you can when you are in Nirvana
you should forget this is already I
think a falsification this idea that in
Nirvana you are somewhere there in a
trans no you are here with all the
people just with a different attitude
but you can be fully active here now the
problem of course is if you accept this
position what does it mean
ethically again I claim there is you
know the problem that I already
approached there is no
guarantee that horrible thing cannot
happen like this was a big shock of me I
read two three books on if there is a
nightmare of a human person this is Paul
pot you remember the leader of Kare rou
in cuchia
cambodja well all descriptions agreed
that there was even a myth within the K
rou that he reached the highest
Enlightenment he was an incredibly
gentle soft person always inner peace
and so on and so on so what I'm trying
to say here
again uh what I'm trying to say is that
uh
uh there is nothing which prevents you
from reaching
inner Enlightenment and go on doing
horrible uh things now you will say
compassion but is not the basic Buddhist
attitude that of compassion compassion
with all suffering beings and so on and
so on but let me assure you this problem
was solved long ago with the wonderful
notion of compassion at War you know
like you can also do you can do all the
killing but with compassion and so on
and so on then you have another problem
here which I think makes it even more
what uh Buddhists many Buddhists admit
that you can reach something
like Nirvana also through biochemical
means with simple chemical interv
intervention you don't need to go
through all the meditation blah blah
blah so uh the problem
is does this ruin then the undermine the
ethical status of meditation that is to
say is there a distinction between let's
say real Enlightenment where you
meditated worked hardly to reach it and
simply taking appeal and finding
yourself in a blessed State Owen
Flanagan a cognitivist who is also close
to
Buddhism proposed what he calls here a
normative exclusion
cause I quote him cases where happiness
happiness in the sense of Buddhist
Enlightenment is gained by Magic pills
or is due to false belief do not count
because the allegedly happy person must
be involved in cultivating her own
virtue and happiness happy States born
of delusion are undeserved my point is
why why if as he admits it it's exactly
the same inner
State okay then uh the next
uh uh sorry uh so again uh because of
all this my the only uh yes here is the
quote from Suzuki if you don't believe
me it is really not he the killer but
the S itself that does the killing he
the killer had no desire to harm to do
harm to anybody
but the enemy appears and makes himself
a victim it is as though the SW performs
automatically its function of Justice
which is the function of Mercy wonderful
description of killing and so on and so
on so uh you know what I'm trying to say
here now really to conclude I was too
long two things first uh don't misund
understand me I am not dismissing
Buddhism in any way it's an absolute
abolutely authentic experience I just
claim it doesn't have a necessary
imminent let's call it moral or whatever
content let's not cheat
here it's as Suzuki said a technique of
achieving inner peace you can do all the
torturing you want I don't believe and
it's quite interesting to read for
example I have a book on Tibetan ethics
sorry Tibetan legal system where it
describes in what wonderful way
wonderful in a terrifying sense in what
wonderful way although they did not do
the
killing they nonetheless did it for
example in in traditional Tibetan
justice of course you don't do the
killing life is sacred but they whipped
a criminal and chained him in Winter to
a tree outside so he WR and so on and so
on you can do it so what I want to say
is that my lesson would be just
a double first let's accept the
Gap inner Buddhist peace meditation is a
great thing but it's not the
answer I think we should again maintain
a minimal gap between inner authenticity
and let's call it ethics of uh acting
together with other people and so on and
so on my uh uh my second conclusion here
would have
been that uh I am that to locate what
really I'm sorry I'm talking in mega
generalities now what really divides
East from West if I may use this terms
probably in a wrong way but nonetheless
is that what nonetheless I find
attractive in West Western tradition is
terribly Politically Incorrect what I'm
saying now it's that uh in contrast to
this idea don't get involved remain
maintain an inner distance isn't the
entire Western ethics starting with
Plato precisely ethic of an ethics of
falling
into opening yourself to an encounter
like falling in love our Western love is
not this peaceful Buddha smile it's out
there something and you fall fully into
it you know this idea of fall Gilbert
Keith Chesterton my favorite Catholic
theologist Al I'm totally an atheist of
course puts this nicely when he says
that in all other religions you have a
fall like man falls from God only in
Christian got himself false into the
world Incarnation and so on and so on so
what I'm saying is
that uh what I what I am tempted to do
here but even here I'm not sure if maybe
some Buddhism can do it it's a very
tricky point it's uh you know at least
I'm totally opposed to Star Wars
Buddhism I will stop immediately to Star
Wars Buddhism you know which is you know
how how Anakin Skywalker became Darth
wader by getting to identify too much
love no I mean uh my friend coin
karatani a Japanese leftist told me that
there is nonetheless a Buddhist
tradition which says no Nirvana does not
mean maintain inner distance Nirvana
means fall fully into the
world in the sense of fall without
Reserve you lose your ego not by some
inner meditation but precisely you lose
your ego by falling through falling
radically into the world accepting fully
the world and even okay I should maybe
have stopped here but my basic message
again would have been that uh uh it's
very that maybe here there is an
irreducible ethical line of division of
how I'm tempted to claim that what we
need precisely today when a kind of a
false Buddhism is becoming generally
accepted ontology is precisely to to to
Advocate the fall not wise dist like
engage yourself fully step out of
yourself fall into it I think this is
for me the ethics that we need today I'm
very sorry I was too long and I
improvise it because this is part of the
work in progress but I am very grateful
for your incredible patience thank you
very
much you said the left needs new master
signifier so just going back to what
you're talking about with poetry and how
poetry sort of animates
totalitarianism is that really what the
left needs so I'm maybe thinking about
like what would an example be like Phil
Ox you know during the 60s and7 he
thought we needed someone who is both
Chay G and Elvis Presley is is this
something that you're kind of thinking
that you know how poetry kind of leads
to animating see your point Master sign
let me be clear not every poetry I mean
I'm definitely not saying that I don't
know Paul Salan leads to totalitarianism
or what all I'm saying is uh this that
what I mean by Master signifier is uh
again uh
I don't like
this ecstatic left where you know we are
all out there together and so on and so
on in ecstatic moments of Freedom what
I'm obsessed with and this I mean with
Master signifier is but what happens the
day after are we strong enough to impose
a new order like what will the new order
be I mean for me the true value of a
revolution is not those estatic moment
moments where there is 1 million people
on the Square that's easy to do what
interests me is what happens the day
after because you know at some point
things as we put it return to
normal not functioning and how will the
changes be felt there and this is all I
mean with the master signifier Master
signifier is here simply the name for a
new for a new order if you want it like
this you know like uh and here again I I
see a big problem it's as if even
uh
like it's the problem for me it's of
course people always tell me but you ask
too much we cannot now give a detailed
blueprint of what new Society we want
but I'm not talking about this I'm even
I'm talking much more fundamentally
about the basic blueprint of what are we
striving for and I find already here a
lack of Elementary
like what do we want do we still want
capitalism but just you know with a more
human face kind of kesian welfare state
capitalism do we want I don't know a
stronger state do we want just local
communities to it's it's pretty
frustrating this and this this is not
just an abstract problem for example it
was a clear problem in Greece when Sera
the radical left party almost won the
election I was it was incredible I was
asking them I met the guy CH as the
leader okay if you win what will you
do apart from these negative gestures
like reject uh austerity measures and so
on what will you do will you like
nationalize not National Li and it's uh
it's pretty frustrating at this level
and I don't think because the again the
answer I get is I want too much we
cannot talk about this now okay but I
think we should because exactly in
Greece and in some other countries you
know uh we cannot say oh there is time
we will see when we come there no we
have to think now about possible
Alternatives and so on and I'm heing
even a pretty tough guy like I think
that the thing that we should abandon
this is very evil what I will say now is
this the true secret dream of the 20th
century left neither stalinist communism
nor social democracy but this idea of
non representative direct democracy in
local communities where you know
transparent no representative this works
at a local level but in order for this
to Works to work at at a local level you
have to have a very efficient Global
organization how will you do that and so
on here I find such a lack of even
imagination like take the big heat Neer
heart at the end when they approach this
problem of both first two big books that
is to say Empire and multitude all of a
sudden San Franciscus is quoted and you
get some kind of a mystical Vision you
know the way I see it is that the
question I don't like this all this
Delian micro local metaphorics so where
the enemy is the Big M whatever
organization and this uh local networks
and so and no I think we will have to
reinvent precisely large Global
organizations how to do that and so on
and so on I'm not a total pessimist here
I think that one reason to act is you
know when people tell us but you cannot
really change it my answer is clear my
answer is but things are already
changing are we aware how quickly we are
leaving behind this even standard boura
Progressive capitalism if we allow
things to go on the way they are going
on now I think in about 10 15 years
maximum 20 we will leave in some kind of
new authoritarian World which we will
not even recognize and so on even going
to towards the so the new idea of the
human the old idea of human of human
subjectivity is disintegrating going
yeah yeah yeah that's my point here yes
that my point is not to paint some dark
picture we will be neuronal automata and
so on but it's an open field of a camp
we have to confront the problem what I
don't agree is for example the habian
solution which is basically a very
conservative solution no wonder that H
must co-wrote a book not really co-wrote
they just together texts with whom my
god with ratzinger today's Pope and the
his H solution is a negative gesture
it's saying since it's dangerous to play
with our brain since it uh limits our
freedom we should set up a limit and we
should not do it and here it may
interest you like I had a big debate
with some Bishops even in in Munich or
Vienna I forgot years ago and I asked
them you remember now I'm referring to
this standard Catholic argument we
shouldn't mess with our brain I mean do
this all this biogenetic psycho effects
because in this way we lose our
responsibility and freedom man is not
just a machine man has an eternal soul
but I ALS always have here an absolutely
naive counter question if you not you
you but if you are and catholic whatever
Christian you believe that you have an
eternal Soul isn't it that then The
Logical answer would have been I don't
care do whatever you want with my brain
you cannot touch my Eternal Soul if they
believe that we have an eternal Soul why
then are they so afraid of me if I'm an
evil scientist messing with your brain
do you know incidentally that there is
one the only good Christian answer that
I got here it's a wonderful one it's the
uh radio apparatus answer they claim
it's a nice way out that think about our
brain as a radio receiver we do have an
eternal soul but our brain is tuned like
tuned to the good radio station to
receive message from the soul if we play
through bio gentics with our brain we
will mess it up it will no longer be
able to I don't think it work but you
see my point I think we have to accept
the the challenge here I mean I'm just
uh otherwise it will be horrible we will
have new and new uh revolts like we have
them now uh you know here in Greece
Europe whatever and but then the result
will be nothing just more and more
frustration so you've already killed me
off about four or five times this
weekend the reason why I'm I know what
you're are longing for when you already
that down you know typical Hollywood
fight when the bad guy wins when the guy
is already down you kick him the last
time into the head you know so I have I
have to do that we have another question
over here um tying uh last night's
screening into yeah today's talk uh I
was just wondering if you were aware of
uh you talk about David Lynch a lot I
was wondering if you were aware of his
whole engagement with transcendental
unfortunately I am yes the same uh
Howard Stern also practices it and I
didn't know about Howard Stern but I
know about I know the man his idea is
that if you I think if you get a certain
it's almost like what stalinist called
the jump from quantity to Quality that
if you get a great a large number of
people meditating together it must be at
least 10,000 then it will unleash some
energy which and so on and so on you
know I know but uh it's
uh like uh what surprised me at a
different level is how often David Lyn
David Lynch even he really must be some
kind of unconscious genius who really
doesn't know how he does it for example
what is for me the absolutely Supreme
most painful scene from Wild at Heart
you remember the traumatic scene where
uh William defo who plays Bobby Peru the
bad guy har
Laura Duren you know not physically but
just intrusive like close to her and
with that disgusting mouth whispering to
her say me say me say me
you remember what then happens finally
terrorized she says me and you know
it's a such a vulgar you know what he
does then he steps back and says oh
thanks for the offer but not today I'm
not in a mood maybe another day thanks
the point is that precisely by treating
it precisely by not raping her
paradoxically he humiliates her even
more and okay in a book Lynch on Lynch
he is asked how did you come to this
scene and he gives a totally stupid like
oh it seems a good line to say I don't
know what he mean he really doesn't know
what he's doing I mean no so uh but this
is often the case with artists I'm not
saying let me very careful here I am not
saying we had a good Lynch doing movies
and a bad Lynch involved in older
budhist stuff and so on maybe somehow
and we often have with great art this
Paradox that somehow in order to do a
good product you need the most stupid or
naive uh uh
ideology things are very paradoxical
here often and this is what always
interests me how illusions are done
sometimes necessary even stupid
Illusions no but yes I I I am aware of
that yes but Lynch is still not my
greatest Des although you know I know
even much darker things about Lynch I
don't know if it's true but a friend
from California told me that when he was
a couple of years ago David Lynch asked
about unemployed people no he said I
would cut off all the unemployment these
are just lazy people who don't know like
it's
a I even prefer not to talk about his
direct politics so uh's no democracy
here I have the the final say uh we have
one last question on the side here
please uh yeah uh I was fascinated about
what you were saying when you're
connecting subjectivity to void in a
certain sense but this the classic I'm
not originally no no I know uhan stuff
precisely but what I wanted to ask you
was how you engage with the critique
that would come out of viken Stein about
the kind of cartisian position and I
want to ask you that precisely because
some of these issues about bio gentics
and the seeming disintegration of the
category of the human uh some people
could say that that sort of validates
the critique of the cartisian Void if
you like I I just wanted to ask you how
you engage with that position it's a
very nice question I'm soet we don't
have time you know what okay I am
bluffing but not totally bluffing I know
about Vidgen Stein my answer would have
been this one I'm always looking for
potential allies where that uh I don't
think it's enough to distinguish two
Vidgen Steins the early
one tractatus clear correspond and this
plurality of games language games the
so-called wienstein founder of so-called
wrong terms or I claimed that when he
approached the topic of of uh certitude
and so on there is another dimension
there he become aware that there he
comes close to subjectivity I claim he
became aware that as it were the this
plurality of language games and so on
doesn't cover the entire field what he
evokes with the topic of certainty is
something much more radical and there is
a philosopher who claims who came close
to this you know he I know he is
personally Half Crazy blah blah blah but
he was hailed when I was young as a
genius soul kpy you know his book his
claim to fame is uh naming and necessity
it's an extraordinary book but then he
did wienstein on
rules where he goes precisely into this
problem which is no longer just late
wienstein what I claim saw that again
the philosophical investig that standard
viin of family of different language
games is not enough I claim name a void
appears there as to cartisian
problem I'm always a faithful cartisian
because I claim that we should
distinguish first every feminist should
like deart you know that deart is the
father of feminism literally the first
modern philosopher who fully developed
feminism was a pupil of I forgot his
name of deart who claimed precisely
kogito means kogo doesn't have sex and
so on and so on but you know what my
answer would have been here even a
Buddhist answer if you want Pro Buddhist
answer that the mistake is at the very
beginning of the cart when he makes this
faithful step from kogito ergosum which
is a purely performative evental entity
cogito is just a process of kogito
totally non-substantial the step from
here to Res cogitans too a think which
thing which thinks is illegitimate so
that the card I'm ready to criticize but
I think the cart uh I'll put it in this
way I claim that anti-humanism begins
with the cart in the theoretical
Renaissance is humanism is this
celebrating the fullness of personality
and so on but the lesson of all radical
modern philosophers the cart k Hegel is
no our the wealth of our personality is
just a mask there is a void there and
this void okay it's a big
problem how to combine this void with
the Buddhist void but at least here they
are on the same side so again I think
that in contrary to what sometimes
Michelle fuk seems to claim and so on I
think that this transcendental tradition
of modern philosophy is absolutely
anti-humanist it's not human being the
wealth of human being is the mask of a
void and here again uh
even
cognitivists I think would have accepted
this in the sense that I as a cartisian
I'm ready to sacrifice all content my
authentic emotions whatever whatever all
these can be what I don't give away is
the void itself and it would be
interesting to I don't have time now
sorry I talk too much to re you know all
I'm far from thinking that all
cognitivists are stupid if I put it in
this way there are many who are stupid
plainly stupid like I'm sorry to tell
you Steven Pinker is plainly stupid I
think he simplifies it so much says
stupidities but already with Daniel
danet e often he as you know denet is
stupid when he wants to do a big general
image like in Consciousness explained
when he explains the origin of religion
but when denet uses specific example
makes points and so on he can be very
intelligent so what I'm claiming is that
intelligent
cognitivists do things for example I
read dozens of books per first report on
that is in my paralax view of how all
intelligent cognitivists try to locate
the moment of
self-consciousness as a moment of some
kind of a circular short circuit
claiming that you have Consciousness
where you no longer have a simple line
of causes and effects but when uh a
cause is as it were retroactively
posited by its own effect there must be
a kind of a causal circularity and they
describe it with very nice metaphorics
and so on so again my answer to you
would have been that neither Vidgen
Stein nor cognitivists especially
cognitivists uh are not viin also but I
say especially cognitiv because often
the critics of cognitivism treat them as
some idiots who thought you know we have
a clear neuronal mechanism we can
explain everything no no you can find
true pearls there on Theory I'm far from
playing this typically Continental
European game of dismissing cognitivism
as naive and unable to confront the true
transcendental subjectivity and so on
and so on I take brain sciences and
cognitiv vision very seriously so I'm
afraid uh we're out of time at this I'm
sorry I talk too much I'm sorry I want
again I want to thank slavo for coming
the entire weekend it's been very
wonderful having you here I'm very
honored to have you here and I thank
everybody
no I'm grateful to you to be because you
saw what I was doing today I wasn't
totally selling the old I'm
sorry if you were disappoint because I
really tried to give you the first
glimpse of work in progress what I'm
struggling with now I'm tired of just
repeating the old lenan points and so on
you know I want really in very native
way to engage with all these and well
the work goes on thank you very much I
mean it sincerely I'm not bluffing now
thank thank you very much for your great
patience here with me thank you very